When a Twitter user pointed out he could create
another social media platform for much less
than his $44 billion dollar Twitter purchase
and reminded Musk that he apparently said
he wouldn’t sell Tesla assets unless it
was to fund Mars, Musk responded: You might
be right.
If he walks away from the deal, he’s obligated
to pay a $1 billion termination fee.
However, Musk reiterated he’s still committed
to buying Twitter in a follow-up tweet.
Besides the fears and questions about how
the Twitter acquisition impacts Tesla and
Tesla’s stock price, there’s been a whole
other tidal wave of criticism since the world
found out that Elon Musk struck a deal to
buy Twitter.
Here’s just some of the reaction from news
networks.
You cannot let these guys control discourse
in this country or we are headed to hell.
We are there.
Trump opened the gates of hell and now they’re
chasing us down.
If you get invited to something where there
are no rules, where there is total freedom,
do you actually wanna go to that party, or
do you decide to stay home?
And that’s a question for Twitter users.
"If [the “neo-Nazi faction" of the GOP expands
in Nov.], we may look back on this .. as a
pivotal moment, when a petulant & not-so-bright
billionaire casually bought one of the most
influential messaging machines & just handed
it to the far-right”
To that comment, Musk tweeted: “NBC basically
saying Republicans are Nazis”
Elon Musk’s $44 billion dollar purchase
of Twitter has clearly triggered an outpouring
of disgust from some on the left.
Twitter’s top lawyer, who earned $17 million
last year reportedly cried during a meeting
about Musk’s takeover.
Tennis star Martina Navratilova has vowed
she’ll never buy a Tesla.
Democratic congresswoman Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez
is concerned about an explosion of hate crimes
because a billionaire controls a massive communication
platform.
To which Musk jokingly tweeted back: “Stop
hitting on me, I’m really shy”.
AOC clarified she was referring to Mark Zuckerberg
before deleting her reply shortly after.
Progressive users of Twitter who advocate
for progressive social justice causes have
been nervous about the leadership change.
They fear Musk will promote conservative content
on Twitter.
And give those on the right a stronger voice.
Musk has said he’ll allow Trump back on
the platform.
During a recent Financial Times interview,
he called banning Trump a “morally bad decision…and
foolish to the extreme.”
“I think it was a morally bad decision,
to be clear.
And foolish to the extreme,” he said
He’s said timeouts are better than permanent
bans.
Conservatives have accused Twitter of censoring
them so they’re now cheering on Musk’s
takeover because he has vowed to reduce censorship
and bring more “free speech” to the platform.
When Twitter prevented users from sharing
a New York Post article critical of Hunter
Biden when his father was the then-Democratic
presidential nominee, Musk said it was “obviously
incredibly inappropriate”.
Twitter explained it banned the article because
of its policy on hacked materials.
However, conservatives accuse the platform
of not applying that policy evenly.
Musk is actually NOT a conservative.
At best he might be described as a moderate.
He said he was a registered independent when
he lived in California, the state he loudly
left for Texas.
He said he strongly supported Barack Obama
for president but believes “today’s Democratic
Party has been hijacked by extremists.”
A meme he recently shared showed a person
who had leaned slightly left and was now surprised
to find themselves right of center even though
their own views remained the same.
That’s because according to the meme, the
“woke” left has drafted radically further
to the left.
Musk has made it known that he is out to save
the world and often touts his other ventures
– Tesla and Space X - as being part of that
mission.
In the same way, he believes free speech is
vital to saving democracy.
Yet his critics believe too much free speech
is dangerous.
They wonder how Musk will deal with harassment
and disinformation on Twitter.
Although Musk views Twitter as the digital
public town square, the left-leaning Guardian
argues:
“Twitter is less like a ‘town square’
and more like any Starbucks, McDonalds, or
shopping center.
It has other obligations and interests that
are at odds with completely unfettered speech.”
Content moderation is difficult.
The former Reddit CEO said Musk is “in for
a world of pain” and will “be forced to
censor things” due to the difficulty of
enforcing free speech online.
Musk didn’t appear to take his comments
seriously at the time.
His response to the “novella of a thread”
as he called it was: “Twitter is way overdue
for long form tweets!”
Some observers compare the chatter from those
who have vowed to quit Twitter as akin to
those who said they were moving to Canada
after Trump got elected.
Most never followed through.
If he decides to go ahead with his purchase
pending shareholder approval, Musk is counting
on his critics to stay on the platform.
Tweeting: “I hope that even my worst critics
remain on Twitter, because that is what free
speech means.”
The news sent Twitter shares down more than
20% in premarket trading.
Twitter’s stock price has been on a roller
coaster of a ride.
There are so many other ways to grow your
money.
JP Morgan recently said: “Alternatives are
no longer optional”.
They’re essential.
Fintech platforms are giving people access
to investments they could only dream of in
the past.
One of my personal favorites is investing
in art.
I love art.
Art investment used to be reserved for the
uber-wealthy but now, it’s possible thanks
to Masterworks.
Masterworks is a revolutionary investing platform
that lets you buy shares in multi-million-dollar
artworks without needing millions yourself.
Since I’ve started talking about them on
my channel, they’ve been BLOWN AWAY by the
response from you guys.
Masterworks says my viewers have invested
over 225 thousand dollars on their platform
from over 1,000 accounts.
That’s 250k into paintings by Banksy, Basquiat,
and Picasso, to name a few.
Each of these three paintings Masterworks
sold has given a 30% rate of return to investors.
Now past performance is no guarantee of future
results, but 30 percent is amazing.
If you want to join other Newsthink subscribers,
just head to my custom link in the description
or pinned comment to get started investing
with Masterworks.
That’s masterworks.art/newsthink
Thanks for watching.
For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom.